what about when you see those surveys
where girls say that they there's these
surveys I've seen that say that women
will go out just to get a free meal or
something you know like they're not
actually intending to do and to me that
sounds terrible because what what you're
saying like does are they not thinking
oh now I I kind of owe him
something but secondly why would you
really want to go for dinner with
somebody that you're not into you like
they probably just don't give a you
know what
I I don't think I would want to go for
dinner for 2 and a half hours away or 2
hours with somebody that I was just not
pay for it you know yeah do you know
what I mean it's like weird but they
they're probably just broke you know
yeah